well here we are in Osaka Japan with AJ
ho
hi AJ and you go for the name AJ it's
not yeah Anthony or Alfred when it
really is Allen but ages it alright and
we've known each other we never met but
we've known each other for what ten
years it's been longer than that because
it's thirteen or fourteen thirteen or
fourteen effortless English yeah is it
still effortless they still efforts
English sorry so AJ and I we share a lot
of views on my concerning hmm it has to
be of course not effortless no but if
you enjoy it you're not forcing yourself
I do something and you're looking for
ways to enjoy it and particularly when
you actually go to use the language
you're not worried about what you get
wrong or what you forget right and that
way you're enjoying it you're engaging
with the language and stuff right now
and AJ is a user of link which very much
appreciate lutely yes and you have it
thank you and you have a channel yes on
YouTube yes it's my name just your name
AJ hook AJ hope do you have other
activities like a blog uh you have
effortlessenglishclub.com is my main
website right but really YouTube and
then there's the audio part is a podcast
you know like I'll do just oh you're the
same show it's the same show but it's a
part yet yeah okay
and you help your English learners a
with English because of always spoken in
English yes spoken very clearly without
being you know deliberately sort of
slowed it down you enunciate clearly not
all native speakers do right and so the
message there is both that they get to
see vocabulary and structure but also a
lot of encouragement yes you're very
popular yeah
and a number of your followers are very
happy to hear that we were going to get
together yes indeed because I think
there's a lot of you know like
cross-pollination between the two yes so
first question is can you explain so you
aren't going to be living in Japan now
for the foreseeable future or yes you
know we uh my wife's Japanese so right
have been you know we've been getting
long visits here and I just had two
babies and we've decided we're gonna
raise them up here okay
so now I'm in Japan and yeah we have an
apartment here in Osaka and we're going
to stay we were commenting on how nice
it is here the the level of servers the
politeness are gentle in a way it's very
very pleasant I mean every country has
its has its pluses and minuses and I'm
sure there are minuses in Japan too but
there are many many pluses it's a very
pleasant place to live despite how you
know crowded it is everywhere right so
what is the AJ philosophy when it comes
to language learning you know the the
idea this that the name effortless
English right it actually was actually
it's kind of similar to your book that
write the it was also inspired by the
taoist idea right the Lu way right and
and the idea was effortless effort right
but it was kind of a clunky name right
it's just how effortless English is
right but the idea is that you know of
course on one hand it's a lot of effort
a lot of time right learn English or any
language right the idea is that it it
can feel you can be doing something that
spending a lot of effort for example
exercising who love exercising right the
one hand physically working very hard
but you can it can be something that
feels very enjoyable right that kind of
flows state you know where you feel like
well this is enjoyable and a it feels
effortless in a way right what is
explaining the flow concept
so the flow idea being that you know
you're so you're you're enjoying what
you're doing you're so focused on what
you're doing that you you know you it's
a feeling of almost forgetting time a
little bit right and you don't feel
right at you're making this you know
tortures difficult painful effort right
right which is what school feels like
you're right and I think one of the one
of the elements like I've looked at a
little bit at this flow theory and
there's a hungarian with an
unpronounceable name yes that's right
chicken chicken is highly or something
like that yeah and but the idea is
you're doing something that is a little
difficult right a little it's not too
easy like you know if people stay with
simple stories all the time you never
push themselves to harder stories for
example in language learning right then
they won't achieve that sense of flow
they'll get a hell keep a sense of
boredom right then you get bored on that
yeah that's the stress on one side and
then kind of boredom on the other
exactly and it's finding that it's
finding that sweet spot where it's a
little bit difficult but you feel you
can do it yeah and then you find that
you are doing it you climbed the
mountain one of the problems that sort
of first language learners have is they
don't have the confidence that they're
gonna get there yeah
so they they're climbing this mountain
and all they feel is is the hard work
and the sweat and without any real
confidence that they're going to reach
the top of the mountain right and I
think what you do is you give a lot of
them that sense of confidence that they
can make it and that they shouldn't
worry about you know they're climbing
the mountain a few rocks fall on their
head right don't worry about it keep
climbing exactly exactly that yes and
and and and trying to well it's you know
so many people especially with English
we can rise around the world people are
learning English in schools and so
they've had all these years of that kind
of you know tests and grades and
memorizing and it's good it's also kind
of stressful and it creates a mindset
that is they're so focused on you know
oh what level am i right now and yeah
what level of my it might be 1 b2 right
and then getting all stressed out about
it and totally forgetting that I can
just enjoy this language I can listen to
things that are interesting I can like
one thing now I'm doing we have a book
club and a movie club where you know so
once a week I'll do a video and we're
all just we choose a book and we all
read the first the chapter and then I
talk about it and discuss it and and it
kind of I guess they get people
interested in and fascinated with the
book that maybe before they thought I
was too hard to read right like we did
brave new world Wow
which is you know fairly Tufton right
for some people if it's too tough they
can just watch our videos and get a lot
of the ideas of it and this is something
that you saw this is you talked about
this on your YouTube channel and in your
podcast which is the same but where do
you then go through the book well I just
I'm doing it very generally kind of like
a like like I said like a book club
where you get together so I'm not going
through you know word by word so what I
encourage people to do is to maybe watch
the video first right I give a overview
of the chapter and I'll pick out some of
the vocab a little bit right and then
I'll say now go try it that's how to
read okay so we encourage them to go off
and do they aren't necessarily
interacting with each other right well
there's a live chat oh god so they can
ask questions during the video yeah like
a live stream yeah okay so they'll ask
questions about different things or good
fries or then we just have a discussion
about the ideas it's really good I mean
the thing about language is it's a form
of exploration so they're exploring
whatever movie or book you're exploring
with them or helping them explore right
you did some Spanish then you
when did the Camino in Spain has a form
of exploration are you living in Japan
right learning Japanese yes exploring so
we shouldn't get too hung up about what
our level is but just to kind of keep
exploring
absolutely and that and that's what
makes it enjoyable you know think that
as I was telling before that my
experience in Spain with the Camino was
so much more rich mm-hmm even we have
thought that level you know be one I'd
say yeah was probably where I was at and
that's the way I was it was so wonderful
just to chat with people and it was a
great feeling that you know call up and
get reservations and function in Spanish
there yeah even at a low level but you
have a sense of achievement I have a
sense of achievement and now you know
now it's like well like I I we're
planning to go to Spain again maybe in a
year or two and the family and I'll keep
going with it well question what is the
sort of age group of your the members of
your group call it people who follow you
on you that's it's kind of similar what
you're talking about it's it's I have a
few younger folks but it is more in the
I'd say 30s and 40s 30s and 40s that's
what we find as well I think 30s and 40s
yeah and maybe we'll end on that note
I'm beginning to feel that this whole
idea of lifelong learning mmm and that's
the people who you know do link are in
that age group yes and 50 and 60 and 70
I mean I mean 70 lifelong learning is
where it is I think language learning
doesn't have to be lying returning my
wife likes piano or exam een but
something people you know learning
doesn't end that you know University
right you know it's something we want to
be doing all our lives so on that note
and we're about to go after dinner marks
coming down from Tokyo so I'm very happy
to have finally had it finally see you
pretty embarrassing yeah okay bye for
now
[Music]